Oh Papa I had the worst nightmare  what uh what was it buddy I dreamt I  wasn't an elf at all I was a human it  was awful  buddy I I love you and nothing nothing  can ever can ever change that but it  wasn't a dream  buddy here you're not an elf what do you  mean I'm not an elf you're in your human  you and me can you speak up you're a  human being no wonder I'm always  freezing we decided it would be best if  we let you think that well you were one  of us I mean I I felt sure when you when  you crack six feet that well you know we  would come up I just thought I had a  glandular problem your glands are fine  so so you're not my papa  I will always be your popper it's just  it just that you have you have another  popper you have a biological papa come  over to my desk